wir sind jetzt hier beim krankenhaus was
ich dazu die lage ein
lageplan ist die
hübsche spät wird besucht mehr grip
zusammen und erzählt geschichten und
zähle auch
die stadt um die stadt zu vergessen aber
wie gesagt das ist das aktuelle
nachgewiesen
wir haben auch viele angriffe von
angriffen gehört der russischen armee
auf krankenhäuser und auch zivile
einrichtungen
jetzt wieso das ist klar zu sehen dass
menschen diese lieben infrastruktur
eine welt
ich hätte das leid der zivilisten ein
ihr team bouygues sa die vororte von ihr
hören dass über zwei millionen menschen
noch in kiew sind was hast du schon den
kindern von den frauen von den menschen
die in der stadt sind wenn man sieht ja
draußen kaum noch leute
also viele
in das krankenhaus hier sind links seht
ihr links zusammen mit einem arzt hier
jetzt dieses krankenhaus besucht wir
bleiben einfach so lange drauf wie das
möglich ist und nehmen wollt hier live
in diesem moment mit
in eine situation der bürgermeister der
stadt irrt der hier das krankenhaus
besucht
sind krankenschwestern zusammen
natürlich sind die beiden boxer hier die
bekanntesten figuren in der ganzen stadt
und hier sehen wir die räume
so nämlich weiter mit ich hoffe die
bindung bleibt stehen
so gesehen
kam eine dame sterne wir sind live dabei
gewesen wie paul ronzheimer mit den
klitschko brüdern vitali klitschko der
bürgermeister von kiew unterwegs ist in
ein krankenhaus in einem vorort von
vitali und wladimir klitschko die sich
wirklich die ganze zeit um die bürger
dort kümmern und die leitung ist jetzt
wieder da wir geben nicht auf und gehen
wieder zurück
wir sehen jetzt hier
vitali ist die situation im krankenhaus
[Musik]
denn dass alle soldaten die 500er das
ist alles so keine soldaten
und wahrscheinlich auch bei fraktion ist
aber das ist seine
[Musik]
mutter ist die vorstadt wo momentan die
kämpfe will deswegen
gibt sie als bürgermeister rahn
wir sehen hier weiter wie ein arzt die
lage erklärt vitali und wladimir immer
beide zusammen hier an ihrer seite
und versuchen sich hier ein überblick zu
verschaffen
zwischen
diesen dramatischen tagen wir bleiben
einfach mal weiter drauf das ist eine
live situation in diesem moment hier in
kiew die beiden klitschko brüder die ein
krankenhaus besuchen
500 menschen sind dort
untergebracht verletzt an den letzten
tagen 500 sollte der doktor erklärt hier
gerade die situation
thomas
ja das sind eindringliche bilder
man sieht noch mal ganz nebenbei bemerkt
wie groß die beiden sind die sich ja
wirklich auf sie warten jetzt
vor schützend vor ihre bürger stellen
ruhig war damit
wir schauen uns mal die situation hier
weiter an in dem krankenhaus und es ist
ein meister im
überblick behält von der lage
können nicht versprechen dass das signal
immer gut ist es ist natürlich hier
teilweise auch im untergrund
das ist hier eine anlage wo man nicht
will dann kann das ist sozusagen ein
logistisches lager thomas aber ja so ist
ein tagesablauf hier von vitali
klitschko und wladimir klitschko die
sich 24 7 hier um ihre stadt kümmern
nach auch ziemlich verschiedenen orten
um am ende eine sicherheit zu bekommen
beziehungsweise einen überblick zu
bekommen wie die lage in der stadt ist
tatsächlich gibt es weiter angriffe aus
dem norden aus dem süden und weiterhin
die versuche die stadt ein zug essen und
paul es ist ja auch so dass in diesen
krankenhäusern die versorgung ja gar
nicht mehr so gut stattfinden kann weil
die menschen natürlich ja auch wenn
luftalarm herrscht in einen bunker haben
müssen wie ist das bei dir vor ort jetzt
gerade in diesem krankenhaus
ich lade die situation gibt es auch wir
gehen jetzt hier noch mal wieder weiter
mit raus natürlich gibt es einen bunker
und dieser punkt ist dann benutzt wenn
es so zu sagen wenn es sozusagen
luft alle angibt